what was your first fight where Who and  the result  my first fight it was an amateur fight  at an Indian Native American PC  reservation up in New York um I fought a  guy named Vincent Morales and there was  where yeah Upstate New York who Vincent  Morales and the result was a second  round rare naked choke which I seem to  be pretty good at  who is your toughest training partner  by far hands down Bar None I mean I got  some other really good guys but this guy  is just I'm telling you you have to see  the sparring sessions and the training  sessions to understand exactly what I'm  talking about this guy is something  special and I really do think he will be  the first Georgian UFC champion  foreign